[Musica]
[Applauso]
di solito nei ted si parla della prima
storia dei propri successi nella propria
storia personale anche degli insuccessi
e di come poi magari sono stati superati
se dovessi fare questo tipo di discorso
dovrei partire dalla periferia romana da
dove vengo si sente chiaramente che sono
romano
da un quartiere dormitorio il quartiere
popolare di quelli da casa mia raccordo
anulare c'erano 3 400 metri di prato e
basta a proposito di questi quartieri di
queste realtà ultimamente è uscito il
libro di uno di un amico mi ha chiesto
la postfazione e questo
nella postfazione inizio con una frase
questa la frase dice non abbiamo niente
per questo vogliamo tutto in questo
niente in questo tutto realtà poi c'è la
scelta del mio lavoro perché vedendo
proprio da quel contesto li
vedevo
giornalisti fotografi e registi insomma
passare e raccontare in quel caso nel
caso insomma del del posto di cui parlo
nella postfazione
un vecchio locale caldaie uno scantinato
abbandonato fatiscente e abbandonato da
vent'anni e loro vedevano uno scantinato
fatiscente e abbandonato io insieme a
quelli invece sono nati e cresciuti in
quei contesti vediamo
potenzialmente un teatro che non c'era
vediamo una palestra dove tutti e tutte
potessero fare sport accedere alla
cultura e quindi ho deciso di raccontare
storie il mio lavoro è quello di
racconta storie al suo in inglese va di
moda la parola storyteller io preferisco
in italiano a volte sembra un po
svilimento però io racconto storie e
quindi anche oggi realtà non vi voglio
parlare di me perché credo sarebbe meno
interessante vi voglio parlare invece di
regia regia è un ragazzo che
afghano la sua storia diciamo può essere
lunga
7.700 km km più km meno quasi tutti i
percorsi a piedi e nel momento in cui
come dire regia iniziamo la sua storia
diamo una connotazione e appunto in
afghanistan quando lui aveva 12 anni una
mattina come tante
va a scuola in un villaggio vicino a
quello su viveva in un piccolo villaggio
a nord di kabul
e a quel punto
come dire tornerà dalla scuola il
pomeriggio e la sua fine la sua famiglia
era stata sterminata la reggia e hazara
molti di voi è una parola che magari
dice poco o nulla
gli hazara sono una minoranza etnica in
afghanistan sono circa il 10 per cento
della popolazione poco poco più e sono
musulmani sciiti quindi sono una
minoranza all'interno del mondo islamico
i talebani sono sunniti ossia la
maggioranza della
all'interno dell'islam
gli hazara parlano far sì che potremmo
chiamare persiano insomma quello che
parlano in iran mentre i talebani
parlano pasto perché non vengono da
dall'etnia bastona principalmente
in realtà questo è bastato queste due
differenze insomma realtà tanto altro
principalmente queste due differenze
sono bastate negli anni per portare
avanti una pulizia etnica vera e propria
nei confronti degli hazara ecco gli
afghani
fino al 15 agosto mettiamola così
teniamola come data quando poi talebani
hanno ripreso il potere questo
intervento la ho pensato prima purtroppo
è diventato più attuale oggi prima di
quel prima di quel momento c'erano due
milioni e mezzo di persone
rifugiate tra l'iran e il pakistan
nel mondo ce ne sono 3 milioni questo
sempre prima ecco lui è resa
nel mondo ci sono c'erano almeno sempre
prima del 15 di di agosto c'erano tre
milioni di persone afghane rifugia nel
mondo quindi la gran parte di loro
grandissima parte loro sono tuttora
principalmente in iran e in pakistan e
quindi come dire ovviamente gli hazara
per questioni religiose per questioni
linguistiche principalmente fanno in
iran dopo dopo che razza di e resta solo
all'improvviso a 12 anni
in pochi giorni
chi lo conosce insomma contatta uno zio
che si trovava in iran e riesce a far
arrivare fino alla frontiera
e qui la sua storia come dire incontra
il primo problema
perché potremmo pensare hanno la stessa
religione
la stessa lingua e realtà passare quel
confine non è proprio facile la polizia
iraniana se incontra intercetta gli
afgani che sono entrati illegalmente in
iran lì lì ferme riporta principalmente
in due campi per profughi sono dei veri
e propri lager insomma chi ci è passato
racconta cose
bestiali e lo zio paga un trafficante
che lo lega sotto un tir
lui 20 a 12 anni si è ritrovato legato
sotto un tir per ore mi ha raccontato
che pensava di morire ogni secondo a
volte provato ad aprire gli occhi ma poi
li ha tenuti quasi sempre chiusi e
diceva mi troveranno qui morto ancora
legato sotto un tir che sta quando
magari proprio al controllo della
frontiera invece per fortuna è arrivato
vivo è stato i primi mesi della sua
nuova vita insomma in iran è stato
chiuso in casa perché aveva paura che
fosse perché ancora non ha i documenti
quindi
che fosse rimpatriato e invece dopo un
po per fortuna vista la sua storia a
sono arrivati i documenti ha potuto
studiare molto portato per le lingue
parla un inglese ottimo ea 18 anni ha
fatto una scelta perché comunque la la
vita in iran per i rifugiati afgani
nonostante la lingua nostante
la religione non è proprio facile
diciamo che fanno lavori di fatica fanno
lavori poco retribuiti e quindi lui ha
deciso visto che era portato per le
lingue visto che era insomma comunque
non aveva la sua famiglia con lo zio a
18 anni insegue il sogno europeo parte
parte e quindi si dirige verso la
turchia perché la turchia chiaramente è
la porta verso la grecia verso l'europa
e quando acco turba incontra un
trafficante è l'ultima città dell'iran
prima di uno dei tanti punti quella
frontiera è molto molto grande è però
c'è questo passaggio che è fatto di
montagne montagne alte neri gelo
sono sono terrificanti sono partiti in
dieci e abb ann la prima città in
turchia dopo otto giorni sono arrivati
in
82 li hanno lasciati sulla strada in
quelle montagne non si sono potuti
fermare perché sarebbero morti anche
loro sono morti di freddo e mi ha
raccontato in quel caso che sentiva la
morte nel cuore perché chiaramente i
suoi compagni di viaggio stavano per
morire ma non poteva
salvarli non poteva aiutarli doveva solo
continuare altrimenti sarebbe morto lui
sarebbero morti gli altri ecco allora io
mi occupo racconto storie questo
l'avrete capito io mi occupo
principalmente di migrazioni da tanti
anni tutti i contesti sociali ma poi in
particolare alle migrazioni e quando
racconto le rotte migratorie perché ne
sappiamo veramente poco o nulla per
esempio di queste due prime frontiere
che vi ho raccontato in italia non si sa
quasi nulla e
faccio un esempio un esempio un po
insomma anni 90 supermario non so chi se
lo ricorda adesso so che è pure tornato
di moda è praticamente un videogioco
della nintendo dove ci sono i livelli e
ci sono i mostri no per poi superare
come più o meno quasi tutti i giochi
ecco i livelli sulle rotte migratorie
sono i paesi i mostri sono le frontiere
il problema per la quale che nel
videogioco se perdi il mostro di rimanda
indietro o ti uccide ma e altri certo
tutto finisce il gioco e lo riprende e
purtroppo di frontiera invece si muore
perché la vita è una sola non abbiamo
altre possibilità
e quando sei fortunato ti rimanda
indietro magari ti rimando indietro di
un solo livello altre volte e lo vedremo
insomma di più livelli purtroppo ecco da
quel momento da quando regia gli altri
hanno lasciato questi due compagni lungo
le montagne tour che
lui ha affrontato diversi livelli e
diversi mostri grecia
albania kosovo serbia bosnia
quando io l'ho incontrato nel gennaio
2020 facevano meno 5 e meno sette gradi
fuori un supermercato lista con la
maglia termica calzamaglia freddo
incredibile lui era con delle scarpe
vecchie strette quindi indossate a mo di
ciabatte senza calzini vestito leggero
solo con una coperta di file e mi ha
chiesto dei soldi era fare il
supermercato perché voleva voleva
comprarsi ovviamente qualcosa da
mangiare siamo diventati amici da quel
momento insomma ho cercato anche un po
di seguirlo abbiamo siamo stati diversi
giorni insieme
e lui io l'ho conosciuto che aveva perso
di fatto un pezzo di umanità gli occhi
erano spenti l'ho chiamato lo spettro di
rezza perché non era veramente lui era
era qualcosa di meno umano rispetto ad
un ragazzo in quel momento di 22 anni
era in viaggio da quattro anni e questo
umanità lui l'ha persa nel game il game
è il tentativo che dalla bosnia le
persone
come dire provano ad arrivare a trieste
prima tappa sicura in teoria per poi
continuare qui arrivano a ventimiglia
dopo trieste da ventimiglia se riescono
a passare dopo diversi tentativi vanno
verso il nord europa però resta in
realtà aveva passato già anche un altro
confine l'unico di mare che è molto
pericoloso è quello dalle coste turche
fino all'isola di lesbo che una piccola
piccola no neanche troppo insomma isola
greca e in quel pezzo come dire il
mostro è piccolino sono dieci miglia io
ho fatto con tante missioni in mare con
le canne gira il canale di sicilia nel
mediterraneo centrale e vi posso
assicurare quel pezzettino rispetto a
quanto è grande il mare è veramente
piccolo e lui mi ha raccontato che anche
in quel caso pensava di morire non è
riuscito a togliere la testa lui si era
nicchiato ha messo la testa in mezzo
alle ginocchia non è riuscire a guardare
neanche per un secondo fuori lui non lo
sa non era neanche gliel'ho detto perché
sarebbe stato un po infierire ma quel
pezzo di mare è piccolo ma è veramente
pericoloso perché ci sono tante correnti
loro usano dei gommoni pessimi
ovviamente come tutti i trafficanti
usano dei comuni pessimi e quel pezzo di
mare ci sono tantissimi scogli e pietre
a pelo d'acqua non si vedono se non sei
esperto non le vedi devi conoscere
proprio quel pezzettino e quei comuni
fanno così si aprono negli ultimi 5 6
anni sono morte centinaia di persone
così inghiottite dal mostro inghiottito
dalla frontiera è chiaramente non c'è
l'altra vita
ecco
quando invece lui prova prova il game da
da b a c da velika kladusa che sono due
città a 4 ore di macchina da trieste
stanno sotto casa nostra potremmo dire
lo prova 30 volte fino al gennaio 2020
quando l'ho conosciuto e per 30 volte
viene intercettato e respinto di soldi
alla polizia croata che ferma le persone
ultimamente uscito un video vi invito a
cercarlo di
della polizia curata finalmente abbiamo
un video lo denunciamo da anni ma almeno
abbiamo anche un video in cui
incappucciati passamontagna picknett
picchiano i migranti così per loro per
il loro divertimento ecco la polizia
croata fa questo li ferma li picchia in
realtà dovremmo chiamare la tortura cioè
col nome proprio perché
picchiare con un manganello sotto la
pianta del piede in modo che i piedi si
gonfino facciano male e non poter
riprovare il game e per un po di
settimane e tortura tagliare la testa a
rasare i capelli e fare una croce sopra
sopra la testa perché ovviamente
musulmano quindi rischiare una colpa e
tortura tagliuzzare le mani che è
successo anche questo con le forbici per
così per puro divertimento da parte
della polizia e tortura usate il teaser
senza richiesta anche sulle donne e
fortuna
e lui l'ha approvato 30 volte una volta
addirittura era arrivato in italia
in realtà la polizia slovena lo ha
intercettato ma ha giocato con lui e
altri due che erano con lui altri due
ragazzi come il gatto gioca col topo ce
li hanno rincorsi con i cani ma al
guinzaglio è presente li hanno spinti
verso l'italia lui non era in viaggio da
quindici sedici giorni adesso non
ricordo ma negli ultimi giorni ha
mangiato solo erba per che passavano i
boschi non poteva avvicinarsi ai
prefetti insomma le città perché
altrimenti avrebbero chiamato la polizia
quindi mangiavano l'erba che trovavano
arrestate per fortuna e
alla fine li hanno spinti fino
all'italia poi non è arrivato a trieste
a poco dopo il confine l'anno 90 non
intercettato insomma l'esercito italiano
che li hanno riportati in slovenia che
li hanno riportati in croazia dove
ovviamente sono stati picchiati e a quel
punto è successa una cosa come dire il
videogioco andato un attimino in tilt
non è poi non è tornato in bosnia dove
di solito tra l'altro cosa non che non
vi ho detto ma vengono spogliati prima
di essere rimandati in bosnia e 6 minuti
devono attraversare anche d'inverno dei
fiumi e una volta ma raccontata al che
sta per morire faceva talmente tanto
freddo e non riuscivo più ad andare
avanti i suoi amici lo hanno salvato
però ecco il video gioco in quel caso è
andato in tilt e lo hanno riportato in
serbia quindi ha saltato livello dalla
serbia cosa che sta avvenendo sempre più
spesso lo hanno riportato in macedonia e
dalla macedonia in grecia quindi lui
praticamente un mostro lo ha mangiato
diciamo così e in meno di tre giorni
andato indietro di sei livelli
ecco di rezza ce ne sono tanti e quello
che succede che
tanti diventano pazzi diventano
psichiatrici chiaramente a volte sono
diagnosticati a volte no per fortuna
insomma a volte è possibile
diagnosticare a questa cosa per la
presenza dei medici lungo la rotta ma io
oggi vi ho raccontato in realtà la sua
storia ma la storia di tanti tanti rezza
che si chiamano hartmann si chiamano
mohamed safik e mura sono uomini e donne
che
ormai da anni sono lungo i muri della
fortezza europa muri a questo punto se
ne aggiunge un altro perché la polonia
appena deciso di costruirne un altro ma
che ci sono fisicamente o no perché
magari a volte sono termo scanner droni
agenti di frontex la pulizia di
controllo
europeo delle delle frontiere esterne
come dire io faccio questo racconto
racconto queste storie racconto le
storie di tutte queste persone in questi
ultimi sette anni ho raccolto tantissime
tantissime testimonianze e sono storie
che magari a volte non vogliamo sentire
che magari ha dominato pure in parte il
pranzo perché uno stallo e pensare
torture
però purtroppo sono vere e accadono
sotto casa nostra vicino trieste accada
fatto lo re a trieste ma accadono lungo
tutte le frontiere della fortezza europa
e come dire ho scelto di fare questo
lavoro perché volevo dare umanità a
queste persone volevo raccontare quegli
succede ma lo volevo fare con umanità
perché poi tra una periferia di una
grande metropoli e una rotta migratoria
c'è tanta differenza ma se lo sguardo
riesce a trovare l'umanità in entrambi i
contesti chiaramente nella narrazione
racconto può fare la differenza però
attorno come dire a un po al ted perché
altrimenti insomma non avrebbe senso
essere qui
cambiamento no quindi cambiamento
quello che accade nel mediterraneo
centrale quello che accade vicino la
libia a sud di lampedusa quello che
accade lungo i muri della fortezza
europa chiaramente è qualcosa che ci
tocca da vicino anche se a volte non lo
vediamo
cosa possiamo fare perché chiaramente
come dire voglio chiudere in maniera un
po più propositiva più positiva possiamo
fare qualcosa sì si può fare qualcosa
perché ci sono tantissime organizzazioni
dalle più grandi penso da medici senza
frontiere che a treni che psichiatri gli
ospedali da campo a piccole la linea
d'ombra trieste fatta da due signori di
76 84 anni che tutti i giorni a trieste
curano i piedi fanno un lavoro di cura
dei piedi e non solo chiaramente ma
principalmente dei piedi di chi arriva
da questo da questo game dalla lotteria
come se la vita fosse veramente un gioco
no ecco possiamo sostenere loro potere
sostenere loro a volte con piccole
donazioni a volte magari uno si può
prendere che tra una settimana
di ferie e poter dare una mano o
condividendo il lavoro che fanno questo
anche importante perché chiaramente si
cambia la narrazione perché noi quando
parliamo di migranti siamo un po
affaticati perché lo dico da giornalista
perché insomma i media hanno fatto un
pessimo lavoro negli ultimi anni la
politica neanche a parlarne e invece e
invece credo che si possa si possa
cambiare quindi il cambiamento
da questo punto di vista credo che possa
essere
lo posso fare io lo potete fare voi lo
possono fare tutti e tutte perché credo
che sia importante perché reggia e tanti
rese le tante reds ha chiaramente
meritano una vita dignitosa per le
storie che hanno passato per quello che
che passano in libia quello che passano
in croazia e bosnia turchia e in tanti
altri paesi grazie
[Applauso]